ocasio-cortez was celebrating the
departure of Tucker Carlson but one
other institution was also celebrating
the Pentagon from Politico good riddance
Pentagon officials cheer Tucker
Carlson's ouster is just like Avengers
this is just so much like the Avengers
movies that I like hey guys this is like
those movies I saw once about the
superheroes
which one uh were they avenge uh no the
boys where homelanders oh my gosh and he
kills a protester and they cheer for it
I never saw that you didn't see the boys
looks like a spoiler I guess yeah dude
you ruined it uh I really recommend the
show because it's hilarious but it's
very obvious that so it's basically like
Justice League Batman Superman Etc but
they make the characters flawed or
something like that and homelander
basically Superman is Trump and so he
has rallies and stuff like that he's
political and it's like the show didn't
start this way but the crazy thing is
I'm pretty sure the character Stormfront
a literal Nazi is Laura Loomer oh we
talked about it but I'm not but I'm not
exaggerating like I think they actually
tried getting a character who looked
like her and made the character
Stormfront and then were trying to like
basically I don't think the show was
directly making a statement about Laura
Loomer I think they were inspired by him
he doesn't look like her the character
Stormfront she's hot what but the
character looks like Laura Loomer the
character Stormfront like similar statue
characters yeah yeah yeah so I and then
they said I think now we have we have uh
like the reporting is they actually uh
were trying to base homelander off Trump
but here's the thing in the show
homelander at the end of last season is
like he's got a song with him and he's
at a rally and then some liberal throws
a water bottle hits his kid and then
homelander just laser beams him and
blows him up or whatever and then
everyone cheers for it and I'm like I'm
fairly certain that if Donald Trump did
do something like that people would not
be cheering sorry it's just not reality
I could shoot someone on Fifth Avenue
but like if if Donald Trump did go on to
Fifth Avenue with a gun and shot
somebody Trump supporters would be like
what happened why did this happen if
Donald Trump went on a murderous Rampage
people people would be like yo I don't
know about all that but like the way the
Liberals view it is they make this TV
show where Trump is basically Superman
which is also a weird insinuation to
make like they think Trump is literally
Superman and they don't like it and then
he kills a guy and they think Trump
supporters are like Yay they live in a
very very strange scary world but anyway
before uh Sheamus got any more excited
about superhero the point is in an
interview AOC was asked about if America
is heading for for another civil war and
she's like well there's a part of
History that's similar to this Captain
America when him and Iron Man fought and
I'm sorry I'm not gonna let go of this
this is ridiculous elected leaders
referencing Marvel movies it's our
common language now this is the state
religion it's a bizarre pop cultural
polytheism and they look to these
superheroes like it's their Pantheon of
gods and it's extremely embarrassing and
pathetic they're Pantheon it is well so
the story is the Pentagon is also there
with AOC and my point was AOC was
supposed to be this Insurgent character
who was coming into the Democrat Party
and being like I am here for young
people and we don't like the machine and
now she's like Pentagon we're in this
together
so you know yeah they're on the same
team it's it's Captain America we came
together to be to be fair Captain
America was a DOD project
yeah the US government no that is true
no I know that's that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying that's how it
gets into their heads right
it's very industrial military complex
you gotta let it go and then you're
right no but here's a fun fact you know
so before uh World War II superheroes
usually just kind of like solved
problems in their own communities in the
comics like they would beat someone up
who was doing bad things in their cities
and then it was during World War II that
they started making all the comics about
like the superheroes saving the world
hmm yeah so the industrial military
complex changed their own devices
I don't know if I'm not saying it was a
concerted effort by the military
industrial military industrial complex
whatever we want to call it today Tim uh
my point is just that the the um
war effort changed the way that people
saw superheroes which I find interesting
yeah and they're they're an inch they're
a convenient propaganda tool which is
why we're in love with them again they
have um it was trending I guess RT
offered Tucker a job wow
yeah you should take it what do you mean
like within the last day
yeah I think that was the reporting let
me pull it up
and then the left was like this proves
it
let's check it out Tucker Carlson
offered jobs
okay let's get out of here with the
stupid video Tucker Carlson is out of
Fox News but welcome on Russian TV the
ousted anchor was offered work by the
state-run news channel in Moscow that
Echo much of his conspiratorial rhetoric
on the war wait what's the byline on
this
that dude once made up a fake story
about me what yeah yeah he made up a
fake story I can't remember exactly what
it was and then the Today Show ran it
what was it it was um
I can't remember the exact story but
they included somebody some leftist
activist this is my understanding what
happened made a super you know you know
they have those activists who will take
clips of you and then mash them together
to make it seem like you said something
different but they're meant to be
humorous so be like a weird colors like
someone made a video accusing me of
saying a thing that was like out of
context and combined with other things
and then he ran the story and then it
got picked up by a bunch of other
outlets that ran it saying like hey you
can't get mad at us NBC News reported it
NBC news then removed the citation so
there's it created a dead citation so a
bunch of other media Outlets were all
referencing each other referencing
something with no Source that's how they
play that that's how they play Ben
Collins wrote a piece I wish I could
remember which piece it was it was
something about you know Russian
disinformation and Bots that in the
Twitter files this Michael
schellenberger found found the email
where they're like in the like Joel Roth
the head of trust and safety is calling
on this story about Ben Collins
like in the emails he's like this is
fraudulent this is there's nothing here
this is complete propaganda uh that was
a bed calling story because he hasn't
retracted it yet well I'm looking
forward to the rest of the media
collapsing yeah
yeah I was thinking about potatoes I
think by the time you had a potato on
the show while I was gone and put my
name on the title that was great potato
on the show I'm sure it's funny because
we did that they literally did that to
me they're bad friends yeah we put a
potato in that chair and then we put we
put Sheamus in the title card and put a
picture of the potato I mean it's
hilarious I am curious about this though
right so what happens from here let's
say all of traditional media collapses
ooh I mean does the government and the
Deep State and the corporate world all
give up and go I guess we lost I mean
they'll just they'll infiltrate social
media because big Tech already leans in
their Direction like Scrolls the
shape-shifting aliens from the Marvel
that's exactly yes thank you so much I
mean that's exactly what I was thinking
they already have that apparatus
constructed yeah social media that's
what we've been reporting on in the with
the censorship industrial complex I mean
they've got every platform basically
except for Twitter at this point because
of Elon musk's take over so like yeah if
it reverts to social media it's not a
problem for them but but let me but let
me ask you about this is Elon being like
do you have free reign are you able to
just access the files or is Elon like
dripping them out to you and giving you
selection information definitely not the
latter we what how how it worked was we
would go in there and then we would ask
for searches so we'd say do a search on
you know this is an enormous Trove of
files um so every email every slack
message so we'd have to say let's I want
to see the emails from all the emails
from uh Vijaya Gaddy between this date
and this date you know say a five-day
span or something and then they would go
and run the search they would go to
another room and run the search and the
reason why they were doing this stuff in
another room is because they were
extremely paranoid about our seeing any
user data because that's a serious
liability for Twitter so they had to do
everything they could just make
absolutely sure that what we were
getting back was just internal stuff
nothing with user data and then when
they would come back with thousands of
emails thousands of slack messages
depending on what we're asking for and
then we'd spend days going through going
through them so there was no way for
I've heard the accusations that they
were like cherry picking this stuff well
I like what they're doing but I think
Elon needs to hire an internal liaison
basically they need to hire you directly
for Twitter so that you as an employee
are able to see user data then you can
choose to what to search for without
limitation it's it's very very difficult
to know what you don't know it's
impossible to to to to to know what to
look for if you don't know what exists
yeah and so a good component about going
through these documents is going to be
just sifting through at random raw data
and then finding threads but without
being able to access that system and
peruse it you don't know what to search
for so you're you so what's happening
now is with the Twitter files is I think
you guys are scratching the surface yeah
a lot of the information is damning but
it's what we expect what about searching
for some something that no one thought
to search for you know what I mean I
wouldn't know that's the challenge so
like this is this also also the issue
with the hunter Biden laptop people
don't know what to look for so they've
just it took them a year to find certain
stories we had stories from uh the daily
mail coming out exclusive Hunter Biden
laptop reveals you know Joe Biden was
involved in this deal like a year after
the laptop came out because you have to
go through you know 50 000 emails and
you and then you have to find the
context so there might be an email being
like hey I confirmed that meeting with
the big guy you asked about then you you
can't search for Joe Biden doing deals
you can't search for a corruption you
can't search you can search for the big
guy then you can find Nemo being like
Hey we're on for tonight at 10 pm see
you there and then you're like who's
this guy what is he doing if you went to
someone with a laptop and said search
for Joe Biden in the emails you wouldn't
find that one but that one combined with
another one proves he was involved in
certain business dealings which is you
know news that came out a year later
right so this is the challenge with the
censorship stuff because it's probably
worse than we realize how do we search
through this stuff so you go to them
with search criteria how do you know
that what you're getting back is the
complete picture how do you know what's
all the information that's available
when they hand you a little dossier of
let's say 2 000 documents how do you
know it's not three or four thousand
well so first of all it's important to
know that like Elon when we came into
the Twitter files Elon Musk had just
taken over the company he didn't know
what was in these emails you know he
hadn't he hadn't been there the people
running the searches were brought were
people who were brought in from Tesla
and SpaceX because he'd fired half the
staff of Twitter and later on he fired
some more and he replaced them with
people from his other companies and so
they had no idea like they were like
trying to hold this company together
with duct tape and bubble gum while
running these very time intensive
searches for us they didn't actually
want to be helping us they wanted to be
doing their regular jobs but this was
kind of a task to them
um so so first of all like nobody knew
what was in there before we saw it
um I mean maybe some Old Guard Twitter
people but all these folks were new
which were just as fresh to this as we
were and then it would be obvious if
there was stuff missing because we would
see email threads that would just
suddenly end but you know did you
actually see that no we saw no evidence
of anything missing like we like you
would expect to see email threads
starting with no with nothing like out
of the blue anymore
is Elon still giving you access to all
the files not at the present moment but
we hope to be back in why not uh I don't
know I mean he's Elon right but like
he's like okay guys no more searching
have a nice day no it was more like we
did our searches we did our reporting
um where we hope to be to have an
opportunity to go back in that was
obviously be at his request his
invitation we can't go in there without
him
um and uh but that's not at this
particular moment like we hope to be
back in did you ask uh to search for
Alex Jones
we did not do that search that's an
interesting one to do but that's that's
also part of my point like without being
able to just get free reign so much as
limited and the Alex Jones thing could
prove collusion between the networks at
the same time yeah I mean we did have
free reign while we were in there and we
hope to be back in there but to your
point yeah we would need to be I mean I
mean like here's a hard drive yeah start
digging you didn't have that well no but
I don't understand why yeah I mean well
first of all because the user data thing
um and I don't think they can just
separate that also this is a massive
amount of data it's like we're running
searches on it's all the emails all the
slack messages at Twitter for years you
know this is like it's not like you can
just put it on an external hard drive so
the the the the Alex so this this is
this is one of the issues I took with uh
I don't I don't blame Elon Musk for a
selection and journalists I think he
actually did a really good job of
choosing some people to bring on to go
through this it's the best he could have
done but there's probably a lot of
people who should have been given yeah
it was it was too um
I feel like the people he chose to go
through this are in a similar political
that's true also it's important to point
out that he did not choose everybody who
went in there he chose basically he
reached out to Barry and Matt taibi and
then Barry brought in Michael
schellenberger Michael brought me in I
brought Lee fong in
um Matt had a team that he brought in so
he basically invited two people and then
they picked the rest of the people so
this this hand-picked journalist he's
like mad at Matt and Barry Now isn't he
he's not mad at Barry anymore oh okay
that's good he's cool with Barry he's uh
there was a little flap but it was just
over her like tweeting something
critical about his like picking on that
employee or something it was just
nothing
um uh Matt yeah he's Matt's not Madden
well this has all been reported out I'm
not right right right but yeah I think
probably one of the most important
searches after federal government
involvement is Alex Jones because that
looked like a Cascade uh it looked like
a conspiracy to to take one man off of
all of these different platforms I also
wonder if Elon would be like no you
can't search that one because he won't
he's like he's outright said he won't
let Alex back on the platform right well
if he did then we would report that out
that he refused to is there anything
that you haven't been allowed to no
correctly nothing except for now that
axis is basically shut off yeah but it's
it's not no it's not shut off it's not
someone it's not like he said you can't
come back in it's just like we had our
time we did our reporting and then we
have to be kind of
like invited back in you know it's not
like we can't just walk in there we
don't have like passes that we can just
use any time of the day
um so you know it's I don't think we've
been shut out it's just I think we'll be
back in there is what I'll say
but you know speaking of conspiracies
like
this stuff the hunter Biden laptop stuff
it was just reported that that the
origin of the uh of the Russian disinfo
meme came from the Biden campaign and
this has been reported by like two
outlets like it's like this is a huge
story that spells out a literal psyop
like that like it's like all we put all
these pieces together about how the
hunter button laptops um story was you
know the FBI had the computer they had
subpoenaed it there was a receipt that
those were both published in the New
York Post uh we knew so the FBI
definitely had the computer and yet they
were running around to these platforms
saying we think that there's going to be
a uh what appears to be a Russian Hack
and leak dump in a couple of days this
is just like within Days of the New York
Post story breaking going to the to the
platforms and warning them of a of a
hack for information that they knew to
be true assuming that they were talking
about the hunter buying laptop which
seems like it'd be a big coincidence if
they didn't then meantime in the
meantime
um the there was a the Atlanta Council
had organized like a a tabletop exercise
a few weeks before the story dropped
where they invited like National
Security reporters from The New York
Times all these bigwigs to to run a a
tabletop exercise what would happen if
there was a Russian Hack and leak
operation intended to affect the
election involving Hunter Biden and then
they all gamed out well we would
suppress that and we would like to call
it disinformation so all this stuff was
already like and this has all been
documented and it looked like a big you
know big conspiracy in psyop and then we
find out because Jim Jordan released
this this this letter that it was that
Tony blinken had called Michael Morrell
the acting director of the sea the
former acting director of the CIA and
and and
um and didn't ask for but said you know
we're very concerned about this New York
Post story and then Michael Morrell went
on to organize that all those
Intelligence Officers who signed that
letter saying that this has all the
Hallmarks of Russian disinformation
which kicked off the entire thing of
discrediting the story and again and it
was at the past of the Biden campaign
and this has now been reported verified
nobody's talking about this yeah we
so we actually covered that on my
podcast yesterday and it's so insane
that somebody from a presidential
campaign could reach out to Connections
in our intelligence agencies to get them
to fabricate a letter with the names of
50 different intelligence officials on
it saying that this is Russian
disinformation so now you have the added
element of them blaming a foreign power
for something which is unbelievably
irresponsible so that they can try to
get their candidate elected and Trump is
indicted because his campaign supposedly
you know paid off Stormy Daniels at his
behest and they should have disclosed
that like that's a greater example of
corruption than the Deep State operating
at the behest of a member of a
presidential campaign thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday Friday at 8 pm and become
a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time